I'm thinking as a
be careful now
because it sounds like you're putting
trying to put the shoes on
it sounds like you're trying to put the
shoes on
I'm just
[Music]
guys
girls
don't look to me to say girls bro if
you're going to do the introduction do
it
guys girls we're back and you already
know we go straight into it with the
question of the week let me get in close
guys the question of the week I have no
idea what this one is we're building
like it was a juicy one so go on yeah so
the question of the week is slash was
what's your darkest secret oh I did see
this one actually and um Twitter and IG
went wild on it I'm not gonna swear
Twitter went crazy on it dude actually
yeah yeah yeah the numbers because REM
wasn't sure that it would do anything
the numbers did views is it actually I'm
gonna check it out check out and see
where I've gone bro I mean someone
suggested we should do it on Twitter I
don't know who it was someone in here
suggested we should do it
hello I don't know who it was it sounded
like it was me but
anyway I'm ready go on dark and see
what's your darkest secret I hate my
husband first and foremost
ah okay that's tough it is me and my
second cousin had a secret sex oh sorry
I had a secret two-year [__] fest
damn SEC what's second cousin
second cousin how do you how do you
equate that second cousin would be like
your cousin's cousin no second cousin
would be like your cousin bro I know
this one but I can't I can't figure it
out so cousin is your Auntie's kid so my
second yeah so my art is cute yeah yeah
so be like your aunt is kids kid no
second I thought second cousin was your
cousin's kid
ah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's exactly what I just said
your Auntie's kids kid your cousin's kid
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's kids kid yeah yeah my bad your
cousin's kid is your second cousin okay
say less raw
um okay I secretly pray sometimes no I
secretly pray something happens to his
girlfriend he's the love of my life I
want him to myself oh my days bro
bro I remember
God when I was when I was in school yeah
or college yeah I think college first
year of sixth form yeah okay
there was one
um why are you laughing about it there
was there was one thing the story was
always funny there was one thing who was
feeling me okay
basically what happened I was I was
seeing one singing it so I had a it
wasn't my girlfriend but she basically
was yeah it was renowned that we were
doing a team right so it's basically my
goal yeah
and um I'm also I must have got a bit
bit tipsy at one party yeah lips to One
Thing from the year below me No this
must have been second year of college
then because she was in college too okay
lips one first year
after the ships
wasn't really fast about uh in the
slightest okay lips are up when lips are
up on a park bench on the walk home yeah
this is when because we both live like
near each other so obviously I knew her
from college so after the party
we would just walk in same direction and
then she's walking on one side and
walking the other side and obviously
we're gonna just walked together yeah so
we were walking talking walking talking
walking talking it's the fork in the
road where I'm going left she's going
right chatting chatting yeah we sit down
I'm like my knees are aching yeah yeah
let's sit down yeah sit down it's a
chilly night yes yeah we're getting a
little bit cozy yeah yeah
yeah yeah and I remember I was like it's
freezing and I've been going gym like
three times yeah I remember I leaned
over and she was like obviously sitting
down on that yeah picked her up and put
her on my lap yeah I've never felt
stronger I bet because when you're drunk
you're strong
lift her up with ease yeah she's never
been handled that up before yeah with
such care fragile delicious
didn't go any further yeah and I just
strolled home
she
liked me after that
blatantly oh okay I would ask to like
walk with me between classes and all
this stuff and I was thinking yo you're
moving baby you're moving bait walk with
me yeah walking with me to be seeing
glasses and I'm like hey oh man like
you're not I didn't know how to let
people down yeah I was thinking right
and I was like come on you know yeah you
know I've gotta go and all that yeah
yeah she was like yeah I was finding
something she went on MySpace back in
the day Myspace
and back then Myspace conversations were
bait I can't remember I can't remember
how it worked I remember there was
Private DMS on MySpace but there was
also bait convos like comments back to
back okay that you could do
um on MySpace I can't remember how it
used to work but basically she was
having a chat about me
on MySpace with one of her brethrens
basically saying like I like him so much
he just needs to forget about his
[__] ugly girlfriend bro wow my go
must have screenshotted it sent me to
this and was like is she trying about me
I was like whoa you never for you to
come back
I never thought it was gonna happen I
was like wow it bro luckily she didn't
pay out her lips yeah yeah but she's
like what's this girl's problem bro
she's crazy and almost like babe she's
crazy I don't know I don't [__] know
she was like I'm gonna cuss her I was
like leave her alone she's younger yeah
yeah come on man come on man
she's jealous she's just jealous stop it
leave us to Stew in the jealousy exactly
so yeah we're better than that facts
yeah do not chat to her facts wow yeah
that's hilarious I'm a sugar baby and I
have five sugar daddies my family think
I might I'm a psychologist
income five sugar daddies
if you could have um big mountain like I
was gonna say pride aside but pride is
everything
if you okay two questions you as you now
yeah no one would ever know yeah would
you
um
would you pick up a a sugar like a sugar
mama
me as me now you as you now she's
running you like
sound healthy
she's running you like eight bags a
month straight into your account what do
I have to do nothing
you just have to you don't actually have
to do much you have to bang her once in
a while but she's not ugly she's
obviously older she's like 45. you can
tell back in the day she was paying but
now she's obviously lost it yeah yeah
yeah you don't hate banging her but it's
a chore obviously it's a chore yeah yeah
there's other stuff you'd rather be
doing yeah yeah yeah yeah
um you have to bang it like once every
two weeks three weeks once every three
weeks and you have to chat to her
whenever she chats to you
she might want to FaceTime you ad hoc
like
10 minute Face Time like once a week
maybe it's whenever yeah now that would
that would piss me off yeah
eight bags a month though but like the
input's actually very minimal yeah I
know I know but um
I'm very like meticulous with my time
like I don't like people just
unannounced face titles face I don't
have a phone call FaceTime but she
doesn't do it unannounced she's just
like you you you just have to keep her
happy so like she might she might hit
you up on a ft question mark and then
once in a while you might be like oh
babes I'm just out shopping right now
you can pie it off but you understand
that you work for her yeah so you can't
just be doing what you want all the time
okay
um
and you said No One's Gonna find out no
one said that yeah I'm doing it then if
that's fine how long do you think you
could still make it for in a pet because
if the contractual agreement Remains the
Same month by month by month I think I
could do it month on month yeah I feel
like the more and more I do it the more
and more should want
potentially but if she sticks to it yeah
if she sticks to it you think you could
just carry on forever so because you
said Banger once every three weeks so
that's technically once a month yeah
yeah
um I FaceTime her maybe once a week hmm
if those are her two requests like
obviously I'll have to understand about
conversation that's the thing you have
to understand your conversation you have
to give your girlfriend experience as
well so like when you're banging her
it's not just like you're running
through clapping cheeks and dipping like
she wants to spend time with you she
wants to hear about your day she wants
you to listen
[Music]
because the thing with me like if we're
just banging like me and anyone if we're
just just banging I'm not there to be
cuddling all them yeah for me that's too
effective I'm just banging you yeah yeah
I'm not here to be giving you girlfriend
experience because I'm giving you false
hope yeah but if it's a transactional
thing but obviously she knows she's
paying for it still I don't know bro
because I feel that for me is like it's
a lot it is a lot for me to get a lot
because after you bang her as well
obviously you've got that PNC and she
doesn't want like bear cuddles but she
might lay in your chest and like yeah
play with your chest like that on a
finger and you're looking like yuck bro
just stop like I've noticed yeah
so maybe not no all right do you think
you can
probably not that's all that is soon
like bro it's literally the face
something that'll push me over the edge
because when I don't like you yeah I
can't stand you yeah yeah every time
every time your name pops up on my phone
I'm just like this [__] yeah bro I
can't do it anymore and she could ask
for so little of me
um if I'm Not Dead on it I'm just like
oh wow you're annoying yeah wow and I
can't fake laugh anymore and then every
time the face times will get less and
less and less wear like that eventually
I just got the phone here and I'm just
watching TV and she might say something
I'm like ah yeah I know and she's like
baby you're right I'm like listen yeah
call me babe one more time don't do you
yeah babe I'm not your bloody I'm not
your babe little bloody babe yeah that I
couldn't that would drive me five
daddies though yeah that's an income
that is a c and that's a time commitment
it is she must be busy
Monday to Friday she must be busy oh
it's disgusting
anyway what's your darkest secret I
fantasize about my friends during sex
and I have to stop myself from moaning
his name oh damn
Madness that I'm a lonely loser who buys
nudes
oh
why is them that's tough like on only
fans and stuff yeah I'm a lonely loser
who buys nudes you know what yeah
whoever sent that in you're actually not
don't call yourself stuff like that
let's just take the jokes away from the
side yeah let's speak about yourself
like that that's harsh bro self-efficacy
is needed the the morale yeah it must be
Brock I'm a lonely loser
yeah they're lonely's killing me yeah
yeah who buys nudes cause I'm lonely wow
oh that's tough dark twist yes this is
the darkest secret it is the darkest
secret wow I finger my bum in my sleep
okay
I'm three months pregnant what in my
sleep
wait yeah wait I think of my body in my
can you imagine bro you just wake up and
you're just like no again with this
again bro nah no I couldn't that's
disgust that is vile but like in your
sleep imagine it getting good to you
when you're sleeping you don't realize
your your pelvis is rocking you're
rocking your wrist as well as your
you're doing this bro
you're feeling it
I couldn't and you wake up sorry yeah
yeah I couldn't wake up solid dribbling
yeah I couldn't wake up mid
because you'd want to stop but keep
going
I'd scream yeah yeah so that's scream I
need to see someone yeah in my sleep the
thing is I wouldn't be able to I'd want
to see someone but I'd want to see
someone with a balaclava run because
they can't know it's me do you know what
I mean but I need help I need help I
need real help it'd have to be in my
sleep yeah balaclavatic the Cardinals
that's jokes because I already know
doctor patient privilege but wouldn't
work so they're telling yeah it's worth
a malpractice suit yeah it's worth it
facts I need a balaclava damn
um I'm three months pregnant but there's
potentially four baby daddies okay this
is outrageous terrifying I'm only mates
with my bestie because I'm in love with
her dad we've done it and she doesn't
know
that's like Keisha the sketch remember
yes I do yeah that was that was a time
yeah that was that was like unless you
don't know about that that was in the
second one yeah that was like year 10 11
for us it was on Facebook right Facebook
there was like a story has there been
anything like this since no not tomorrow
because there was UK world yeah this is
this is UK wide right there was randomly
a Facebook like post and it was a long
story in like multiple posts yeah then
Max the characters and it was a complete
like novel novel fan fiction
like fan fiction novel called Keisha the
scat okay bro it got raunch this girl
banged everyone he was a scat she was a
full-on fully fledged scare and she
wasn't like year 10 11 as well she was
our age yeah and she was banging the
oldest she was and she was letting Road
man run through her but it everything
got twisted bro she loved you know the
thing is about the way they articulated
the fact that she wasn't even
necessarily bear horny she just loved
knowing she was paying and people
showing her she's paying bro that's why
she was banging these people they they
just like she loved feeling wanted
and bro yeah there was one I remember
this scene bro the scene this chapter
whatever it was yeah yeah where she's
listening to you she got she she'd been
like kidnapped or some [__] right and
then she like escaped or she'd been
dashed out on roadside I can't remember
what happened but basically I remember
she was alone and scared in the rain
yeah so she went to her Brethren's yard
yeah and the bridge wasn't home just the
branch of his dad who she'd already said
in previous chapters she thought was
banging yeah yeah bro and then the the
the girl was at her mom's or her friends
or something like that and Keisha was
like I'm getting kicked out of my yard
I've got nowhere to go it's raining like
can I stay here and the dad's like
[__] sake yeah cool stay here go in
her bed that goes to bed in his bed goes
to sleep in his bed Keisha sneaks in she
sneaks in let's just imagine yeah it
used to be a [__] film on this bro
someone should have made a film
hopped in bed with him and he's like
what are you doing bro what are you
doing she grabbed his tool grabbed his
toy and he said
she says banged I bet
and then dashed around afterwards he
could have faced yeah the the clarity
yeah yeah yeah yeah the shame he
couldn't face it bro nothing dashed
around I was like what's wrong with you
bro
she did
and if your name was Keisha during that
time you were Yes actually it was like
that was the Karen of them yeah yeah if
your name was Keisha yeah you bet first
of all you better be Lang you better be
scared
give up to your name wrong facts
all right I've got quite a few more
what's your darkest secret
we've been paying a homeless man to
smash the car windows of a guy who
harasses my sister
[Music]
um
so every time he gets it fixed smashes
it again and the homeless man has taken
the P yeah to be fair you know what's
mad bro I don't really want to do
anything Sinister but if I did I've
never thought about paying a homeless
guy to do it neither have I
I was watching a documentary life of me
at Karma boy is called
um but there was a breader that was
Duppy in
um there was a better stop paying off
um young men young men that didn't have
support oh God and this was back in like
the 70s
I didn't have any support they were
either homeless or in a completely wrong
City or not they were on living on bear
menu and he will take him and dump him
and doesn't remember that I've watched
this not a lot too long ago doesn't
remember their name because he would
never ask or if he did they never had
any um the idea I'd be on them because
they were so [__] flat broke
um he would invite them to back to their
yard and he'd wake up and they'd be dead
he'd buried them in there buried them in
the yard under the under the floorboards
would you mean he'd wake up and they'd
be dead he'd wake up he just black out
yeah he'd black out because he'd be
drunk he'd kill him somehow he doesn't
remember how like on a Dharma tank yeah
oh he narrates the whole thing as well
he narrated innovates it from prison oh
my God he is dark and twisted bro he's W
like 14 to 16 youths
um youngest of like 14 or 16 for the
life of me I can't remember what it's
called it's a documentary on Netflix
it's jarring me that I don't remember
damn
oh I will find it I will find it Jesus
and I'll spit it back but yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah cool sometimes I feel like I
like listening to like your breakdowns
of documentaries more than I like
watching documentaries
so because I know you love watching
documentaries but sometimes I can't be
bothered especially like the old-timey
ones yeah yeah I'm like man this is
boring yeah like this is so boring and
then but like when I hear from you
you're like wow really I forgot yeah
juicy yeah all right he says the rate
and the whole thing that's crazy
casually
he he opted to go to jail he handed
himself in yeah bro
tapped
random
this is a side track and I really want
to get back to the darkest secret so
guys we're not falling off track yeah
yeah we do this all the time we do this
there's a podcast right called cereal
okay cereals and serial killer yeah I
thought so and so not couldn't it be
some breakfast yeah
um that would have been a that would
have been a tangent yeah yeah there's a
podcast called seriously that would have
been it ASMR would just crunching
um anyway
podcast called cereal right and I think
there's two different seasons maybe more
um but the first season
can't remember the brother's name yeah
but there it's all about
it's like literally kind of narrated by
the woman who's a journalist and she's
investigating a murder right yeah um I
can't remember the details too much he
like murdered his girlfriend or a friend
or something like that yeah but he's in
pen and he's like a teenager okay and
it's like he appealed to her through
like uh
um what do they call it what's that
thing that Kim Kardashian does like the
witness I know that they're like being
like Innocence Project or something like
that
um and like he basically just like this
is what's happened to me I'm in pen I
didn't do it there's like the evidence
is shaky help me and she picks it up and
she's like wow I'm gonna look into this
so she's interviewing him and the whole
like the whole thing is narrated by like
her saying I was looking into this
looking into this and then it would tap
into like a phone call that they've had
but she's asking them so what happened
here and it's all narrated from him in
prison basically like this this is the
story yeah and like through the podcast
you're hearing it the exact same way he
told her okay you're actually hearing
his side of the events okay and um he's
going through going through it and
parole at the start it's so obvious he
didn't do it and then she's like
I can't believe this happened I can't
believe like you got locked up for that
I can't believe like how was this like
not national news yada yada yada we need
to set up an appeal we need to set this
up she's working for him and then
something every now and again something
will creep in where she's like cool so
you told me that yeah
but
I was doing some digging and I went to
like the library that you were at and
there's a few witnesses that said that
you weren't there the time that you said
you were there and he's like oh yeah
yeah yeah that's because of such and
such happened and I had to go see my boy
outside or whatever and she was like but
why didn't you tell me that before in
case I'll start her in and there's tiny
little seeds of Doubt yeah that creep in
throughout this podcast now and again
where towards the end
basically spoiler alert we don't know if
he did or not okay because the seeds get
bigger and bigger and bigger yeah and
then she even like when she's not
talking to him she's like no writing on
the podcast like I don't know what to
believe I don't know what to believe bro
I think he's [__] lying to me okay
but I was so certain he didn't do it
yeah I don't know what to believe it's
juicy I love [__] I listened to it like
three years ago I love Shilling [__]
juicy bro oh my God anyways darkest
secret yeah press play
14 years and counting I'm waiting for
the day my ex-husband finds out our
daughter isn't his
I was talking to someone about this the
other day I genuinely do not think
as a man there's
there's hardly anything on this planet
worse than finding out that your kid
ain't yours
that would ruin a man in so many more
ways than one destruction
because expect 14 years bro that is a
piss take yeah
yeah bro you let me pay for it you let
me pay you let me Bond you let me Bond
yeah I love this child yeah everything
yeah you give like this child is my life
my life and you stripped it away and
then like when you talk about it girls
like this is why I find fascinating
right yeah yeah and this is like I like
to like as much as I can I like to try
and marry up human behaviors with like
um what they like uh like the wild like
how animals act in the world okay okay
and how humans because all humans do is
just like try and justify their own
emotions but like a lot of emotions are
connected to just like animal kingdom
yeah like we feel a certain way based on
just DNA yeah instincts and we just use
our words to like try and [__]
justify [__] and like
when you speak to a lot of women they
find it really difficult to understand
not all women but some women I've spoken
to they find it difficult to understand
how a man can bond with a child and love
a child and care for a child and then
when they find out the child's not then
they can just walk away and never see
the child again and like I can really
understand how they can I don't
understand how it would ever be easy it
would make you want to kill yourself
yeah but um I can understand that why
they can't any longer give anything else
to the child and then like when you
think about like the animal kingdom
there's examples of how females in the
animal kingdom will on some occasion
like uh uh like a sheep for example or
something like that if
if you on that because there's an
episode of Clarkson's farm right
refer back there's an episode classes
Farm bro where like one lamb gets
neglected by its mum and it needs a mum
so they literally just like cover this
lamb in like the flipping juices of
another mum cover it so it smells like
it and dashes it and there's examples
another the the Sheep's like gang you
you're my you okay and then there's
other examples of where like
um flipping Penguins for example when
it's mating season and they give birth
they'll start if if if if the mom's egg
doesn't hatch
the baby dies all the all the penguins
that don't have Utes will start trying
teeth other use they'll just start
walking around trying to tee feuds bro
oh wow they're just taking all the other
oh and then the moms have to fight for
their youth and if there's a ute that
gets lost it gets snagged up by another
mum whereas in the animal you don't
really see that with Dads Dads typically
like
if a lion comes in
as like the new Alpha of the pack yeah
and there's little babies around here
that aren't his he's killing them he's
killing all the the user on his bro and
there's bare examples where the males
will just run up and kill kids that
aren't theirs they don't want they're
not interested they're not interested
they're bloodline or nothing bro yeah
they'll kill the youths and then bang
the girl and get his use in there so
like I can see how like
males in human society like when they
find out a kid's not theirs it's like on
a molecular level it takes everything
from you yeah whereas like I can
understand it again where a woman will
see him like probably doesn't matter
like it's your kid regardless of who the
dad is it's your kid like the kid loves
you and knows you and everything like
that and you're like but it's not mine
he loves me and knows me because that's
your fault yeah fast it's your fault
that's why he loves me
I hate you for putting me in this
position because I need every
ounce of my body is telling me I need to
walk away but I physically can't and you
can't take these 14 years back bro it
can't take you 14 years back and on top
of that you know if you do walk away
You're killing the you as well yeah
you're putting the you through hell yeah
damn it's nasty I I probably would be
afraid to have another child
it would [__] with me mentally
100. I need a DNA test yeah all the time
in the womb all the time bro yeah pluck
a hair from inside yeah I need to find
out yeah because I don't trust anyone 14
years that's my bro no no anyway what's
your darkest secret
um a girl broke up with me because I
wasn't intimate enough I couldn't tell
the boys oh my God
as in he doesn't bag right now
oh he doesn't bang her enough I couldn't
tell the boys she said I need sex I need
a mantle clock me and he's like babe
it's just I'm just not yeah
and she's like you know I get out of my
face yeah you know it actually get out
of my face and he couldn't tell the boys
yeah he can't you can't I couldn't tell
you man yeah never never she left guy
she left me why because she just I
wasn't banging her enough
sometimes I just want to chill and like
cuddle and yeah exactly I just want to
watch TV yeah
also the sex of all the time yeah man
relax it's time for that yeah relax
destroy me tell her to come here fax
um whilst on shift I regularly gave head
to a resident I rehab home I worked at
regularly just head just head
regularly gave head bro to a guy in
rehab you're not helping him
regularly she might be in some way boy
oh my god wow that's mad I'll live for
that in rehab facts I'd live for that
again top while his Top's gone yeah
facts bro well his veins are healing
Jesus I used to spit in my stepmom's
coffee every morning for 10 years oh my
God
the gym teacher used to eat my ass off
the school
[Laughter]
nah brother
swear
do you think any of your teachers ever
banged any of your girls in your school
um
I like to say no but me saying that it's
a boarding school as well that's what
I'm saying I'm trying to
I can put my I have no evidence
whatsoever yeah yeah just to clarify you
have no evidence whatsoever yeah but I
can bet money
that especially a night yeah oh in
Nigeria I I can bet that one of them
teachers I don't if they've won a bank
but it would have harassed the youth
before swear not that I've seen anything
but
I'm thinking as a
be careful now
because it sounds like you're putting
trying to put the shoes on
it sounds like you're trying to put the
shoes on
I'm just
also you're about to say if it was me
and I'm just no I was gonna say I'm
thinking as a 32 year old man now okay I
was gonna say if it was me because it's
not me but I'm thinking because
obviously at the time as a kid you don't
think like I'm thinking about by the
time when I was in um Nigerian school
you don't think about
you don't necessarily deep nuances in
terms of like
adults you see what I'm saying yes you
don't necessarily deep them thank you
for your head yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
wasn't sure okay so now you're thinking
back as a man yeah about what you saw
yeah and you kind of think like this
could potentially look coercive do you
know what I mean oh Jesus you know what
I mean yeah I can't really like I said
I'm not I can't necessarily Give an
example but I just know for especially
as well like it's weird because I feel
like in Nigeria is easier to get away
with than you would in the UK yeah do
you know what I mean facts so I just
that's why I said but I guess so that's
why I say I can just probably bet money
it happened not even necessarily it
happened but like to an extent some form
of thing like do you know what I mean
Jesus it's bad to say yeah but I just
have a feeling it did damn yeah and it's
you did any of your teachers recommend
any of your girls oh no definitely no no
no I don't think so I think we had a
thing of like
I don't know if it was confirmed but I
think we had a thing of like um a
teacher
um [__] another teacher and he had a
wife and she came in oh
swear the wife came in on smoke yeah and
it kicked off oh yeah I wasn't there
a student I would love to have been oh I
would have paid money to go to school
that day wow
wow she came to the school bro
scorned wives have no decorum yet why
would they yes
they're all yeah wow I don't think um
I don't think any I can't I can't think
of a teacher that was banging any
student but I remember there was one
teacher a music teacher
whose son came in as a teacher a music
teacher okay I know again I wanted to
thank him oh The Galley wanted to buy
him and Order Galley want to bang the PE
teacher Mr driver okay he never let on
that he did anything yeah he has my
undying trust yeah that he did touch
these girls yeah but all of the girls
want to bang him and all the mums wanted
to bang him he definitely clocked
someone's mum elsewhere yeah bro one of
my boys mums was on it she said I want
to give him a massage
she said this yeah yeah you know she
said this my boy told me at Paris even
she said it
that's embarrassing yeah facts bro your
child is the moms wanted to bang Mr
driver
the name as well I was always wearing
these rugby shoes
[Music]
trust me oh yeah if I was a pea teacher
bro because it's a shitty job yeah I'm
banging everyone's mum I'm banging
everyone's mom you can't stop me well
the husband's gonna stop you and they
can try it
nah but to be fair it's like I'm not
even banging ones with husbands as them
divorcee as you want factual it's them
divorce says you want actual yeah boy
and you're just like no your son's got a
promise you know yeah there's a lot of
kids in there yeah
as long as he drops yeah yeah yeah
uh anyway uh I've got a few more what's
your darkest secret
found out I had the clap and blamed it
on my new boyfriend it was me he bought
me so much
no way wow
I baked space cakes and fed them to my
church
fam they saw stuff that day they
spoke yeah if there's ever a time to
believe in God it's them
they spoke in tongue wow Fox oh
my boy doesn't know that his nephew is
my son nah
my boy doesn't know his nephew is my son
Japan's sister
and how's the sister kept that stump I
don't know bro people do what they need
to do they will do what they need to do
facts facts facts Jesus
I scam granddads or Tinder it's the
Nigerian in me
[Laughter]
I'm not saying this but I've not seen it
but you might have a reputation
you might have a reputation of scammers
it's not our fault yeah the thing is
my Parish generation they've dragged it
with us they've dragged it with us our
Parish generation my parents generation
or our parents generation in terms of
Africans are the real fraudsters yes
real forces the real scammers the real
four one Niners yeah and they passed it
on to their use that's what all these
Nigerians are running around scamming
why I don't know
it's overpopulated that's why yeah facts
you are you've got like 300 M's you've
got 300 M's the same size of the UK
there's the same size as [__] yeah oh
the the capacity is the same size UK
yeah roughly like the same size of um of
land to the country yeah roughly the
same size as you can you've got 300 and
300 M's and UK 60 to 70. yeah out with
[__] scam too I'll scam everyone
exactly 300 M's is like the the same
size as America
not America yeah oh no yes it is bro
Ellis population of America bring that
[__] up I'ma say like 370.332.
what's the population Age 2 30 213 213
yeah maybe 100 Mil short
damn yeah I'll scam too yeah and it's
smaller than the size of Texas Nigeria
is smaller than Texas I believe oh yeah
well Texas is way bigger than the UK so
yeah wow bro that I'll just say I'm too
that's why this man are banging all the
ugly white girls yeah they're trying to
dance yeah yeah they're trying to debt
they need that passport bro because
we're overpopular you said it was such
conviction there's facts we're
overpopulated we need money yeah yeah
yeah the streets are hungry bro wow yeah
bro I never knew I really never knew I
knew it was tough out there it's tougher
wow are you a person just sending you
there
that's inhumane
wow
Jesus Christ my country after all yeah
yeah I love it God love I gotta learn to
it oh gosh you know I mean a couple more
darker Secrets I've got two more I sold
my brother's French Bulldog for 3K and I
told him it ran away I helped him put
the posters up too oh for God's sake man
last but not least I think I like dick
but only if it's attached to a woman
yeah re what yeah yeah what does that
even mean yep yep yep yep bro there was
one I think I told you this there was
one guy I used to sleep with banging man
um
yeah I think I used to sleep with and
then after me she would she would get
boyfriends and then just sleep with me
intermittently it was Lang
you should always cry after
um she would always shot me when she's
drunk
with clap she'll cry after she was
seeing this guy he said like I'm not gay
but if you had a dick I'd want you to
[__] me
wow yeah in those exact words wow not
gay but if you had a dick I want you to
bang me she said like she came to me to
say thoughts
and I was like sounds gay sounds
yeah yeah it sounds pretty gay and like
I mean I'm not trying to label people
and this was this was also caveat this
was like 11 years ago yeah like 12 years
ago I didn't really have the
encyclopedia like I didn't really know
there was in between yeah I just thought
it was pretty binary yeah yeah I heard
dick and [__] me and yeah okay that's
what I landed on
um I'm not sure what we'd even begin to
try and call that now but I was like
damn bro I was just surprised he had the
chest to say that to her
[__] I wouldn't tell a soul that yeah I
really wouldn't and then because there's
also trusted her there's a difference as
well like there's a difference with
saying like I like the stimulation of
something up my bum
as opposed to saying like I want to dig
this specifically you had a dick yeah
yeah like I don't just want anything up
yeah I want you I would specifically you
want a [__] that's mad yeah and it's
interesting
um
but yeah welcome to the show guys
welcome to the show welcome to the show
this is episode 295 we're closing in
lows and into that three days we're
closing in on that freed up and uh yeah
man if you want to close in on site and
head on over to patreon.com shits and
gigs where you can close on these nuts
yes
and G and get indoctrinated to the cult
babies okay binge over three years worth
of content that we've got over there see
the come up see the calm downs and then
get invested in the Discord channel that
is popping off with a few thousand
members uh for conversations every day
get first dibs on live shows get first
dibs on merch get first dibs on uh the
Fantastic new Endeavors that we're going
to be bringing to you guys in the near
future and uh guys moving on from there
if you are watching on the platform
known as YouTube please we're climbing
up the ranks we are we're heavy into the
800ks now and we want that gold one
Milli plaque please help us 1 million
subscribe to the channel there's a
button right in your face right now
you're probably not even paying
attention there's a little red button
just click it there click it there saw
um
with me
all represented the world
so yes
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
I said I wanna stroll with me yachty man
just say what I want yeah
come on listen
uh yo if you listen if you're watching
Youtube guys subscribe to the channel
put the notifications on in terms of
thing in the comments right now finally
guys if you're listening on any of the
audio platforms Spotify Apple podcast
and whatnot please follow the channel
and leave a nice review it means the
world random I saw a review come through
the other day this guy's hating us bro
heinous
bearing them is that five stars guys
yeah one guy put a nice review love one
of the best reviews I've seen man said
best podcast out there as a start
inspired me to start my own I owe
everything to these guys love these guys
four stars oh
bro what what coming are you better
together what do you want bro what do
you want from us
I would have replied did you hand slip
fam do it again do it again yeah I need
that extra stuff let's charge this one
and do it again thanks another email
account but yeah guys thank you so much
for everything you've done for us so far
let's keep it moving keep it stepping
and before we continue REM is not in the
studio today he's taking a little bit of
time off so while he's gone we're gonna
put a pause on top five yeah fooh had
has an appreciation thing
he wants to talk about right now so I'm
intrigued um yeah real quick yesterday I
was on YouTube and I'm randomly
obviously you know Carlos everyone knows
colors the use the music the music thing
I love that same the past all these
menus yeah yeah it's literally
eye-catching um
and I was watching a guy called Saint
Harrison I'd only have heard of him I
hadn't heard of him until yesterday
that's not who I want to shout out but I
had to say this okay Saint Harrison's
voice um
wow I swear yeah you need to listen to
everyone listening now listen to type in
YouTube after this after this yeah don't
stop don't pause the episode pause this
episode to go on YouTube yeah yeah after
this episode make a note Saint Harrison
colors okay wow oh so wow okay you you
wouldn't expect to hear the voice you
hear when you see him okay one of them
once all right um but I was scrolling
through and I was looking through um for
more other because I'd never heard of
him before blah blah so I was like that
was good because I think I saw
a snippet of it on maybe Twitter or
Instagram that I went to watch the whole
thing on YouTube
um then I was scrolling through colors
uh page and I was looking at the views
to see which one had the highest view so
I just I mean make it easy for yourself
make it easy for myself I'll watch a
couple
um and I'm a big fan well I'm not a big
fan I'm a fan of loyalcana have you do
you know law Conor he's a rapper he's a
UK rapper yeah I've heard yeah I can't
think of any tracks yeah but yes
fam he's got a he's had this is his
second I believe uh colors on oh yes
second installment I've got on colors
yeah yeah yeah it's a track called hgo
which me which is meant to say Hugo I
believe
um it's a track about his dad
um and it's very very powerful if you if
you watch it you'll understand but it
made me want to listen to Lord and Lord
Connor again and so I just want to spot
if I just play this music bro banging
bro little Connor swear appreciation
really appreciation he's a music he's a
good good Alice is nodding artist my bro
and you know who do you know who
introded me to lokana hey Bella really
yeah so I can't I don't know who introd
her yeah but when we're living together
in in Manny he she played his um one of
his songs one time it could have been
damsel flight it could have been ice
water
probably ice water banged bro bro he's a
musician he's just is so chilled but
such you you can't help but Bob okay
come on okay yeah he's a really good
musician really good musician damn bro
so low caller appreciation well played I
like what you're doing
um we need more of you and yeah man I'm
gonna Bop him all the way home it's a
[__] gorgeous day today by the way
yes God damn bro it's a gorgeous day
Jesus so yeah that's that's okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna slap that on the way
home Lord Connor yeah yeah cool speaking
of appreciation
we went to go and watch Beyonce the
other day I forgot I completely forgot
yes wow
performance
she obviously I say Obviously we for
context we have never seen Beyonce
before yeah
um and everyone has said she's like
obviously one of the greatest performers
of all time blah blah blah she shows out
and literally none of you are lying bro
none of you are lying we went in there
and I was
I'm not gonna lie bro same as when I
went to go watch Chris Brown I was just
in there on a thugness yeah and just was
like yeah it's cool yeah it's a little
free invitation I'm not gonna say no
yeah it's Beyonce at the end of the day
like let's just go see what she's all
about
blood clots listen bro we stood in there
I said to Fiat before I say again ah bro
I'm not so sure you know because This
Woman's doing stuff she's doing like
Tottenham Stadium
why would you do that surely you'd want
to do the O2 Wembley something like that
why she's doing Tottenham Stadium I
don't know I'll tell you why because
it's the perfect choice
as soon as I stepped in there yeah yeah
I was like right and it was a glisten in
sunny days it was hot and I was like Wow
Sunset was just peaking planes overhead
I was like this is stunning crazy crazy
this is stunning I was like okay say
less Stadium drop top yeah yeah yeah wow
open top Stadium I was like okay cool so
I went in there drinking hand and I was
like okay there play fair play fair play
parole I came in there expect him maybe
to bop my head once or twice
30 seconds into the show my brother
I am in love with you bro you set me
free and again bro it was that she
opened with that note she opened with it
opened with Danish Tree in love I was
like raw and she was singing fam
and the Dangerously in Love is a [__]
song by the way it is it is everyone
knows it I played the entire song back
to back to back my entire drive home
after that mad fans banger
I can't do this thing called life
without you here with me
banger
and to top it or maybe to top it all off
one of the the craziest things I saw was
to just the production value alone the
production was out of this out of this
world I was trying to do the numbers in
my head and it just didn't make sense
and the screen the size of the screen
yeah bro the biggest screen I've ever
seen yeah whoever's oh yeah first of all
Ellis step your [__] up because whoever
her graphic designer is was doing [__]
they were experience CGI yeah off the
chains yeah it was it was [__] nuts
take note say less and less damn bro it
was it was it was crazy yeah it was sick
the dances were crazy the songs were
outfit changes were crazy the [__]
horse that no one even clocked until
they had like a 30-foot horse that just
rolled out no one even paid attention we
also was in the middle and James was
like did anyone see that [__] noise
[Laughter]
when she was finished she's like froze
yeah and then she was trying to keep a
straight face cheering cheering and you
saw this little little smart camera
everyone not yes and then Beyonce burst
out laughing it was the cutest thing
I've seen yeah she's 11 bro bro she's
done this um teen times already this
tour yeah she's at 11 years old
what show what's a show yeah probably
I've said it on the day probably the
best show I've ever seen live
when you said that I was thinking same
but I've got
it's weird because you man probably
won't believe me but I already don't
believe you become one of the greatest
performances I've ever seen was in 2012
or 2013 wireless Justin Timberlake oh
okay I can't believe that oh I couldn't
believe that immediately God swear this
was Circa um
what's the album called
um the one I played part one part two
um oh 2020 2020 the first before the
part two dropped yeah 2020 part one so
that year it dropped off the um suit and
cyber Jay-Z Street
he obviously did his old school oh god
really and James I don't think it was
only me and Toby I don't think you
understand brother that was a finale
I've never seen a performer like it I
can I can actually imagine there's I was
so ready to be like a child [__] and I
didn't even know who you were gonna say
I said there's very few people I could
believe in Justin Timberlake's [__]
one of them just it it couldn't it would
either have to be Justin Timberlake or
Usher one of those two in that kind of
yeah yeah yeah wow I've not seen a
performance like it okay
fantastic okay I believe that I believe
that but yeah anyway not take anything
yeah the Beyonce everyone's [__]
unbelievable and this woman did two and
a half hours flat out flat out the only
time she was off stage was changing
costume yeah she did two and a half
hours
choreography yeah flat out whoever can
memorize that [__] she must have
rehearsed for six months straight every
day facts and it actually planted a seat
in my head because it's no secret within
our team when we have live shows Daddy
doesn't like to rehearse I [__] hate
it yeah I can't stand it and I'm a moody
child bro when we're on stage doing
rehearsals I sit there and I'm like I'm
not running through it again just go go
go go go fuja takes it like a champ and
does the whole monologue again and again
and again to get it right I don't stand
up I hate rehearsal you do it's
embarrassing and awkward and pathetic I
can't stand it yeah but I've changed my
mind yeah I've changed my mind because I
was like that's a show yeah and she did
that she must rehearse that for
literally months and months and months
and months and months and they never got
it wrong and wrong and she would again
again yeah again we have to get it
perfect again and wow it was worth it it
was worth it it was not worth it no
opening like nothing the show started
like 7 25 and she didn't stop till like
10 15. yeah non-stop she must have been
thirsty oh rag every outfit chain
slugging War
bro oh wow she was unbelievable she was
that show was so good yeah I'm a
stepmother rehearsal [__] up real bad
really yeah real bad very very very good
show man Jesus the fact that she's doing
this obviously has to be our last tour
because like we said she's doing like
Southampton and
Wolverhampton yeah she's trying to get
all our money yeah I've never been to
Wolverhampton and I probably never will
I am not going towards yeah yeah so
she's a she's a Golden Goose for going
to Wolverhampton but to be fair I'll go
there to see her if someone offered me a
ticket to the Wolverhampton show yeah
I'll go all right now that I know I'm
yeah I loved it yeah it was fantastic
damn Beyonce it was fantastic well
played man ladies real quick listen up
it's Father's Day it's just around the
corner and if you haven't got a gift for
your dear old dad yet you are in luck
manscape's got your back
your dad's balls
trust us your dad will be thanking you
for keeping his balls in check I'm sure
he will and hey
it's not just a gift for him
you and your mum will appreciate the
results
hey
[Music]
right so don't wait
[Applause]
don't wait any longer yeah use the code
sng Sierra November golf at checkout for
20 off and free shipping your dad and
his package Jesus well thank you for the
most memorable Father's Day gift ever
say less Jesus let's get back to the
episode Another appreciation yeah so
speaking of good shows yeah I've I've
started season four of succession okay I
we can talk because I've seen the finale
of season three so I'm on season four
episode one but I've not started it and
you said you're I'm like I think I'm
like episode five or six of season three
okay
yeah we can negotiate this isn't it he's
in it bro yeah bro times like if you're
rich enough you can have what you want
you can do what you want yeah yeah yeah
yeah get away with what you want bro
when shiv when
um Tom was saying to shiv don't worry
you'll see him you'll see him he'll come
back she was like I know he will come
back oh wait I know he's gonna be okay
yeah boy damn yeah boy first of all
shiv's randomly got a body on her ah
she's got a little
[Applause]
[Music]
but obviously it had to be this way
um God Roman never banged Jerry same oh
my God I was always thinking yeah I
thought it was going to be I thought it
was going to blow his mind yeah supposed
to be fireworks yeah yeah oh but it
never happened yeah so jar involved
um but the seat I won't spoil it bro the
season three finale yeah
tell me your prediction okay I the thing
is I've still I'm not at the end yet but
I have a feeling right it's gonna end on
season three with Logan dying
no and then it's how they're gonna and
then it's the kids fighting basically no
problem
he's been getting [__] ill yeah
the whole thing because the thing is
season three's been my least favorite so
far it picks it does pick up it needs
too because Kendall's not making moves
[__] arm in season three this is life
tanks in season three he reminds me of
um Rick in Rick and Morty
um
speaks and everything he puts he put and
he puts up a brave fight yeah and he
thinks he's the dog's bollocks but
behind closed doors more than depressed
yeah bro but yeah
from when you see those man are you in
Tuscany yet or no
I don't think so no wait till you get to
Tuscany when these men land in Tuscany
stuff starts cooking I'm trying to
remember what just happened uh they just
did that conference where Logan starts
going like senile oh the UTI yeah yeah
that's just happened these men had me
sweating in that episode
I Promise You Now What's his name Frank
Frank yeah I'm not doing Frank's job
when he gave me the note and said keep
going nah you're not doing that to me
wow successions I I preferred season
twos finale to season three's finale I
can't I can't first of all I can't even
remember I remember messaging you saying
season two finale yeah what even
happened again that's what I'm trying to
remember when he got sent he said you're
taking the route
and he's just charged it
yeah
Craig's oh Greg's the Envy peel that
show bro Greg's up and down bro
when um Tom was trying to
um when Tom was trying to um blackmail
Greg or whatever and he said have you
heard of Romulus and so have you heard
of something in something oh yeah yeah
Greg was like um I'm I'm familiar with
the IP
I died bro
familiar with the IP oh Greg you genius
good so perfect in our show bro thank
you genius thanks so perfect bro at
least the comic relief we need yeah he's
so he's so funny hilariously awkward
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh it's too much bro
I love Greg I love Greg but he's getting
a taste of that wealth and he can't keep
it up oh he can only give it oh man I
wanted to sue because it's granddaughter
I couldn't be threatened with 250
million that's a lot of money tell me
today
so you better promise me I'm getting it
I want a contract right now I need
everything signed yeah yeah and
everything's like I could tell the money
was getting to him do you remember when
uh he got that watch
buying it and it was just like okay and
it didn't even work bro it doesn't work
it doesn't even work it's like cool 40K
to impress that girl yeah yeah he's he's
in a different world now yes
but found the season three finale one
name I'm gonna say I'm not gonna tell
you anything else Tom
Tom bro escalates bro bro s Guys Farm
the back and forth between Tom and Greg
when they were scared they were going
pen and grow it's like I heard they do
this and that and I said I've read the
blogs yeah I've read the blogs I'm doing
it
Tom couldn't handle it kept going to
this Diner saying this is what the food
tastes like
wow how did everything on the menu
wow Tom couldn't handle it he couldn't
bro wow yeah it's such a good show it
really makes you want money
that's all it makes you want money power
and wealth facts bro all of it they just
they're just built into that lifestyle
bro did you see there was one where
um I don't know if it's I can't remember
where it was Roman's on a high bro and
he Bops out of the shubs and his car is
just following him yeah
and I can't just keeps following him
yeah yeah yeah oh that was after
Kendall's birthday yeah oh bro
so juicy cattle's pathetic by the way he
is in season three years yeah yeah yeah
his birthday was have you seen his
birthday no I haven't seen him oh
sorry he's so pathetic it's so
embarrassing bro
um but God I love succession and then
I'm here yeah everyone's saying season
four is where it's at where's his ass
bro
it just won something didn't it it got
season finale of something did it really
it doesn't surprise me because I know
the two episodes before that 10 out of
10 10 out of ten on IMDb Jesus only
other show to do that was Breaking Bad
right yeah yeah
um so bro it's going to get juicy I'm
smashing it this week so yeah I've
watched I don't think you might get it
I've watched nothing else no anime I've
not watched anything but succession for
the last week I started having dreams
about it mad I started to have a
succession dreams bro I want it all I
need Logan Road might be one of my
favorite characters going like just
going in in the fictional world do you
know how many times I've said [__] off
in the last week bro that's all he said
he he's the perfect
he's just a perfect person to talk to
because he only speaks facts he only
speaks in a certain amount he doesn't he
doesn't love to chat [__] yeah yeah you
talk factual and you're talking short
form and you take the [__] off those are
these only three ways oh only three ways
and he sits there and sometimes
he asks your opinion when he doesn't
value you that's a value and he'll sit
there and be like
and you'd feel you can feel yourself
talking into a hole yeah and you're
terrified you're terrified and he'll
just move on Ellis what do you think
yeah move on you he knows he holds so
much weight bro wet when this
[__] Logan said to Connor you
know you're on my number one bro and he
was in a whip and it kind of was like he
lost it my number one he got gas he got
gas he got gas immediately bro he holds
so much power he has so much power over
those kids over his employees over every
wife over everyone the way the employees
fear him it's not even funny it's
something I've never seen before yeah
same wow Logan Roy is a character one of
the best scenes with him I thought if it
was the beginning of season three yeah
where they're picking who's gonna be
who's gonna act as the new CEO yeah he's
out of Roman
Jerry and Roman calls him yeah yeah he's
like oh I just wanted to let you know
that yeah
and she's like what I said Romans out
move on
Logan Roy is a character yeah and he's
just like emulating that he's a and I
hate that I look up to him because he's
the worst he's the worst human being I
want that but he he looks forward yeah
he's only focused on money
wow are you family or not and do you
want this money season three finale bro
man said he died
I genuinely thought that's how I think
it's gonna go nah you can't kill him
bro
oh brother yeah Logan's the goat he is a
goat Logan's the goat bro it was a good
thing I can't wait I'm gonna try try and
get the season finale tonight like try
and get for such a long it may yeah yeah
yeah yeah bro taking up a whole day bam
I'm telling you I've watched nothing
else do you know why I did would you
know what finale I did watch Ted lasso
bro oh really yeah is it was it sad yeah
I haven't watched any of this season
good season really yes bro do you know
why very good season do you know why I
kinda kinda kinda kinda kinda fell off
towards the last season
the [__] the bollocks on the um
I can't remember his name the Asian guy
the coach yeah yeah yeah yeah I can't
stand it oh yeah he yeah the
aspirational attitude of this guy he's
is big for you too big for you from day
dog as soon as he wrote One play and
they used it yeah he thought he was the
king yeah can't stand him he wants to
snake everyone that's his character
though it is his character it's a oh
season three is good yeah yeah because
it go it if you watch football as well
it ties in a lot of like the football
politics that's happening in this past
year or so in this season and it just
bodes well okay it boasts so well say
less so we all know I don't watch
football yeah I'm just saying in general
you can kind of tell it they're trying
to make it in sync but uh it's it's such
a good watch and you can't not help but
like Ted lasso as a character oh he's
the best he is the best he is the best
bro
um yeah I will watch it that's the thing
as soon as I get through succession yeah
I can just yummy yummy yummy and
everything else yeah because my anime
has been on pause I've watched nothing
demons I've not watched any Demon Slayer
I've not watched any Hills Paradise I've
not watched
anything yeah David to be fair every
episode doesn't miss so I'm still happy
with that
um I'm only just caught up yesterday
um hell's Paradise gets juicier I'm not
gonna like it what's the last thing in
health Paradise you watched last thing I
watched was
probably the probably the one where
they've just linked the uh kinochi the
female Shinobi yes and uh that's pretty
much it they're just chilling I think
okay you've got a bit to watch I've got
I've I've got bear toys I've not watched
anything in weeks okay
um and uh there was I tell you what I
did watch I watched two episodes of this
anime on Disney plus I can't remember
what's called oh please say the tabs
open one sec this 10 Goku uh diamakio
whatever I'm not seeing that
now so I can add it to my watch list
yeah bro okay is
good it's got it kind of looks like um
animation kind of looks like
um
um chainsaw man
esque it is a bit it is a bit chainsaw
Manny
um not not in like content yeah but bro
just like
10 websites okay yeah so it's like set
in like a flipping futuristic world
where like loads of the population it's
like Last of Us kind of set like people
have their own little communities and
colonies and there's these monsters they
call them man-eaters they come out and
like um just like kill people and like
um
brawl but there's like tiny little
twists and turns where you're like brah
raw raw raw and I've only watched like
two episodes two or three bro and I was
like
say less oh I'm really enjoyed they take
a lot of time and effort into the story
a lot of time it is it reminds me of uh
promised Neverland season one okay I've
added that to my watch list as well oh
my God season two is [__] season one
fantastic okay bro so yeah I'll
definitely um advise that tenkuku damaki
or whatever
um damn bro damn but yeah season three
finale bro
when he puts that phone on loudspeaker
yeah I have to finish season four this
week yeah I'm Gonna Keep yeah yeah yeah
within the week obviously without season
four looking like is it good I've only
watched 10 minutes of episode one oh
okay right first I'm not gonna lie
basically something so pivotal happens
in season three finale three finale That
season four episode one they've
basically
it's like a time-lapse thing it's like a
time Jump oh okay it's not like next day
oh likes from season two finale to
season three episode one yeah it's like
a time job now okay so now we're built
I'm trying to understand what's going on
in this new Dynamic okay so first 10
minutes it's not as boring it's just
like figure [__] out okay right let's
ease into this but obviously it clearly
kicks up because these men are saying
these are perfect 10 episodes from the
episodes I've seen it doesn't make sense
how they can still be yeah bringing out
bangers yeah crazy because I was with
you season three I was thinking this is
a whole season of Kendall just a second
else it's boring me now and then Pam I'm
telling you Tuscany
um
damn you got dilemma Frost knife I do
she said I need help so long story short
I've got involved with someone from work
when I was at a very low point in my
life it started as touching and him
saying sexual stuff to me and then went
to and went to him kissing me and I got
hooked love bomb type of thing
one minute he was telling me all this
stuff to make me think he liked me then
called as hell to me like I didn't exist
then back to sexual innuendos and all
the touching it [__] with my brain
he would say things like we he would say
things like we couldn't just [__] it's
deeper than that but then tell me don't
get in your don't get in with your
emotions he's like dude I'm a woman I am
I am in my emotions what the [__]
now it's getting intense but I know it's
just an ego boost for him when I'm not
when I'm not at work he hears me then
the day before my shift bang he's
messaging me asking me how I'm like oh
how am I like he cares deep down but I
know he doesn't
how do I pull away without affecting my
job he's the type to make my life hell
High key narcissist traits but he's so
in my brain I don't know what to do
so long story short
um she got with a guy at the lowest
point of her life that's deep and they
obviously work together started off very
casual sexual stuff little touch in here
little kiss in there and then a love
bomb drop one minute he's
um being all um warm and close to her
next meeting he's cold as [__] then he's
back to the sexual innuendos and
touching it's [__] with her brain
when she's not in he has a but when
she's about to come in he'll message her
the day before just to reenact sort of
re-sparks on and then so on shift you're
like wife work wife work I'll be typing
and she doesn't know how to pull away
help and he's in her brains he's in her
brain God girls go through it yeah
especially in that close-knit work
scenario yeah I'm telling you ancestral
oh my God this is sexy
sexier
Fortress he's in my brain wow that I
don't know why it is but the way you've
just said it like that I'm like damn in
my brain he's in my brain she can't stop
thinking about him
um
I feel like it's a weird Dilemma to ask
because it's just like
the only thing you could advise is just
stop yeah I don't care what you're
saying just stop that's the only thing
you can do but it's
it's like saying I don't know it's like
going to the gym every day walking past
the [__] the it's like going to the
gym every day and saying to yourself I'm
gonna do cardio I'm gonna do cardio
every single day and I'm not gonna touch
weights but you walk past the weight
rack every single day you're going to
want to touch it bro
you're going to want to tell you because
you're used to it you can't help
yourself but want to pick up a weight
yeah
so what what's the answer then I don't
[__] know quit get a new job that's
the only thing I can advise bro
get a new job nah I'm not getting a new
job because I've I've been in situations
where I've worked with people I found
them attractive
and I've still cracked off my day yeah
but I know I know I know it's it's this
is a situation where you found them okay
you're talking about a fan of attractive
this is a situation where
you're in love with a girl yeah she's
told you I love you
you've banged her it's amazing yeah yeah
yeah every single time is yeah yeah yeah
yeah she just cuts you off as you for a
few days boring cold cold cold you think
what's going on what's going on what's
going on and the day before you get into
work she'll send you in like looking
forward to seeing you tomorrow can't
wait to see you tomorrow we've missed
you around there
I would have to
I would have to be able to charge the
whole thing I would have to because
there is no other choice because the
first couple times has happened where
where
um once I'm out of work she cuts off
like cuts off per se communication then
before I go back to work she's hollering
me again I would have to have charged
the whole thing because
I would need to be in a position where I
would need to position myself in a
situation where I know she's just work
babe yeah and yeah I've charged it in my
brain that she's what we can do with
this lovey-dovey whatever whilst we're
at work and when she just stops
messaging me outside of work I have to
just charge it yeah you're in the
streets out here I'm in the streets
she's in the streets and I have to get
on with my life valid advice that's the
only way you can deep it valid because
it will make work Bay a lot sweeter yeah
a lot sweeter you could turn yourself
into looking forward to it yeah even
though you know for a fact or I know for
a fact she's not my number one or I'm
not her first choice because clearly I'm
only there for her for work purposes she
wants to [__] around what I'm there for
you yeah yeah yeah yeah she's got Mana
yeah she's got a real man at home you
need to change the power down yeah I
need to change the power Dynamic and
make sure that I'm only [__] with her
when I'm at work yeah I can't be showing
her too much outside of work and you
twist the tables man you ain't messaging
her out I'm not messaging her outside of
work I'm doing my thing yeah she don't
know what's going on she's she's
hollering me I'm airing her yeah the day
before you go back to work she texts you
air it airing and then when you see you
act like it's cool
you're a doctor yes spanker bite yeah
what's going on let's give her a kiss in
the cheek and then you just carry on
that's the best way to play it she'll be
intrigued yeah she won't yeah she won't
know what to do yeah she'll grab you
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you just laughing yeah
yeah I'm busy I'm busy yeah so that
that's the way you need to play yeah you
have to switch up the whole power
Dynamic make him need you make him need
you and then when you're outside outside
leave him alone he will if he leaves you
will then he leaves you alone you need
to let him know that he's not important
exactly yeah your number one he isn't
yeah when you're out here you're busy
you're busy you're booked and busy say
less that's the best way that's Peng all
right say that's right I've got uh a few
tweets I know you've got a couple the
first one I've got yeah is
slightly dilemma-ish as well okay fam
when I read it yeah made me laugh you've
probably if this isn't um in your it's
dilemma cookies yeah
I don't know what is okay you've
definitely seen this okay I may have
seen a Bernard
right okay wow I read this right
so I'm 38. my boyfriend is sexy and 22.
he swears he's single but I've been put
into a baby mama Fight Club
he spent the night at my apartment and
several women put Apple Air tags on my
car
fam now I suffer random [__] pins all
over town bro
attacked while getting my nails done
attacked in the Burger King
drive-through wig snatched at the post
office whoa he wants me to take
self-defense classes and stop
embarrassing His Name by losing fights
he says he can't control what others do
but I can learn to protect myself he's
speaking fast though as bad as it sounds
he's speaking facts bro that's jokes
recently I found out he's planning he's
recently I found out he's planning the
fights and has guys filming and
uploading five videos to his channel
it's like oh what I said back I took
everything I said back I'm healing but
I'm also mad as [__] leaving him is not
an option because I don't want the hood
rats to win advice there is no way there
is no advice what the hell is going on
she found out he's asking mandem to
record it and they're uploading it to
his YouTube so he can monetize you have
to leave it you have to leave him bro
what do you mean you can't leave him so
the hood rats can win the hood rats
always they've won they've been winning
they've been beating your ass all over
town all over town in the Burger King
drive through at the post office
all the man said take self-defense
classes I can't help what other people
do I can't help what they're doing big
man you're 38 he's 22 of course he's
[__] up yeah yeah yeah he's
orchestrating the fights that yeah he's
mad bro
he's orchestrated that fight no that's
mad James
that's mad to me wow I could never let's
find out as a woman as a 30 year old
woman I could never find out bro my
little concubine is Orchestra
orchestrating
ass Whoopins not even fights you've lost
everything
I'll get my ass beat Left Right and
center and it's on YouTube yeah yeah
yeah yeah
James I couldn't never I put on my life
on my there is no advice
wow I'm just getting ass whoopings left
right and Center OH belly and back yeah
yeah yeah yeah alien back his front
doorstep I have to I couldn't find out
that my girls sending man them for me
and they're pumping me up brother and
then she's putting ice on my cheeks and
saying you need to take self-defense you
can't just keep getting slapped about
like this because he's probably put
money on you to win one of these days
yeah yeah because the bookies aren't in
your favor it's lost
I hate restaurants that make you say
stuff like yeah can I have the big wet
daddy burger please
[Laughter]
parole oh God jokes by the way jokes bro
jokes I hate stuff like that Daddy can I
have those sleepy sucky ribs please
the Big Daddy's special
nah man can I get those tickle me
tenders tickle tickle tenders yeah yo
that's hilarious all right I got one
quick break on this is a um this is
actually a Facebook post and reply to a
Facebook post yeah yeah hey quick
question what is 19 times 34 reply
please answer quick the teachers are
coming to get the paper
that's jokes
fam I got this one
question what's the worst way you ever
got dumped I think I've seen this one
yeah I've seen this one I've got this in
my back
funny I would I would day shift and he
worked nights he called me every morning
when he got home from work
one day he didn't call so I called him
a woman answered and told me she was his
woman now I asked us to put him on the
phone I asked what's going on he said
you heard that
put him on the phone you know what's
going on what's going on you heard her
oh
firstly
as a man no that's brother no no no I
could never no but because you don't
want tires anymore you hate tires and
you hate Windows yeah yeah who knows
where I live facts
secondly
if that was me
and I'm calling Bae and next man saying
nah that's my thing now I'm like what
the [__] big man is she there yeah put
on the phone I'm like what the [__] is
this yeah you heard him
lock
dial tone
you heard him beep I would
definitely be in prison that night owl
facts I'll be in prison or in hospital
what are the two because if I'm driving
yeah I would have to steer and decide
because you're screaming at nobody yeah
and the thing is the way women work they
only upgrade so I know I can't pull up
to the door without starting to talk
[Laughter]
I can't pull up their handed
bro you have to pull up aside
100 bro so it's oh it's Eva pull up with
satin or I find a ditch real quick and
dive in
there's the only two options pull up
with sight and tights 100 100
yes wow that's hilarious all right I'm
helping my baby dad do a job application
and this [__] just asked me is
he a veteran wow
he doesn't know bro like he doesn't even
know what a veteran is oh that's
embarrassing fam my last one this was
straight to the point I think I like you
reply think again
block me think again wow yeah Jesus
Christ I met I met a bunch of Harvard I
met a bunch of guys from Harvard
yesterday and kept pretending like I
never heard of the school just to piss
them off
one of them legit turned red when I said
Harvard is that like a little Community
College thing
bro that man the only reason they go is
clout yeah fat so you better remember
yeah facts that's crazy to me Bills
bill's due and men in my inbox talking
about link [__] I'm ready to Rob
something
God I
trigger warning I don't miss being broke
bro I don't miss it for a second I never
will I I don't miss it for a second bro
it was tough
it was tough yeah uni times was
different for you oh you didn't want to
work anyway yeah that's the thing yeah I
hated being broke but you didn't want to
have it damn did I hate work
the time that I hate work I hate work
more than I I hate being broke yeah a
lot of people would not understand that
but I hate about more than I had been
broke I hated one but I hate it being
broke
yeah well mama raised the wrong one bro
she was she raised the wrong one
yeah you worked bro and she begged me to
work she didn't understand I hate work
more than I hate being broke
it's hilarious
hunger yeah you wanted it yeah the
lifestyle oh Jesus thank God for this
factual
told her I cheated she smirked and kept
on doing her makeup what does that mean
initiative first
ah damn I think I need a therapist for
this but anyway once I took his pen home
by accident I was so obsessed with him I
put it inside me and then drenched it in
perfume and gave it back to him the next
day
wow
disgusting that is disgusting actually
disgusting
all right uh this is a message and reply
so this the word the acronym
i-l-y-s-m and the question is what does
that mean
I love sucking your meat oh
oh
I love sucking your meat instead of I
love you so much I love sucking your
meat
um
I lost one if you're an RN I need your
help ASAP reply I'm a real name what's
up reply no I'm talking about a
registered nurse I saw that one
yesterday I'm a real name what's up
that's no who Scrolls through Facebook
and just sees a request
I need to step up
bad signals up wow what do you need what
do you need I'm RN yes that's jokes I'm
a real what's up
how can I help
thank you for joining us guys if uh if
you're a real one we'll see you on
Thursday patreon.com Jason gigs if
you're not if you're a fake star yeah
we'll see you next Monday on Monday
[Music]